[Music]
good morning welcome back relief for
america's workers could be on the
horizon
lawmakers inching closer to a deal that
would approve
billions more for the paycheck
protection program
but as you know by now shops and
restaurants are closing at
devastating rates and americans can't
wait any longer joining us with more
on when this deal could be done senator
marcia blackman senator thanks so much
for joining us on our program
i mean but look you've heard the stories
you've seen them on our air you've seen
them elsewhere
people are struggling when is this going
to get done well todd you're right
people are struggling and i see it in
tennessee
every single day as i'm talking to small
business owners
as i'm talking to people in the live
entertainment
industry and bear in mind they were shut
down
overnight and we continue to push
forward as you know
we've had a bill on the floor of the
senate twice
and each time democrats have voted
in lockstep against that funding and
then you hear nancy pelosi
come about and say well now that we're
going to have a new president
as she's hoping where it's okay
to vote for funding and how terrible
that she's admitted
using people and their plight as pawns
in order to get her political way
i find it to be absolutely disgusting
but we are trying to reach an agreement
we would be hopeful that we can do
another round of ppp
uh plus up in unemployment insurance to
add that extra 300
a week bear in mind people lost their
jobs through no fault of their own
and then of course money to speed along
the vaccines and the antivirals and
therapies
money to get schools open because
i hear it every day people want to go
back to work
children want to go back to school yeah
well well this bipartisan bill includes
288 billion dollars
in support for small businesses and ppp
loans which would be much needed relief
can you say with confidence that
something is going to pass before the
end of the year
oh i cannot because twice we have put
our legislation on the floor
which is the extra ppp and
the plus up in unemployment we could
have had this
done two months ago two months ago
and think about the impact carly that
would have on individuals
who need that extra three hundred
dollars a week
but basically because you've got chuck
schumer
and nancy pelosi who would rather pay
play politics than solve a problem
this has not been done and if they think
it helps them politically
in races in georgia they're not going to
do it
they're going to wait and let people
suffer
and it as i said to me it is
absolutely disgusting it's quite a
situation to watch
from afar as you see these businesses
suffering um
let us switch gears to obviously the big
talk of the town the fda
meeting tomorrow to decide if it is
going to grant emergency
use authorization for of course the
pfizer covid
19 vaccine i i mean i think
a lot of americans are wondering what
i'm wondering
if it's an emergency if we're looking
for an emergency use
authorization the fda does not seem to
be moving at a
speed that i would consider one you
would do an emergency i hear emergency i
rush i hustle i do all that
seems to be taking its time what say you
uh what i say about this is this is
exactly the reason president donald
trump
uh started operation warp speed he knew
that the bureaucracy was moving too
slowly to address a pandemic so he
called all of the pharmaceutical
manufacturers
to the white house and said let's get in
behind this and get the job done
he put the operation warp speed project
in place
this is a medical marvel that in this
short period of time we have not one but
two
vaccines that are ready for approval
that we
have antivirals and therapies we have
vaccines
three and four in the pipeline that are
going to be
close behind this and it happened
because
he took an action he made a decision he
said we're going to do this
i remind you that back in 2010
with barack obama and joe biden
what happened when they had the bird flu
the h1n1
they went from april to october before
they declared it a pandemic
60 million americans were infected
and while it was much less deadly
still you had americans that suffered
because
it took them six months to make up a
fund
this is the difference in a president
that takes
action and a president that wants to
move
things to committee for discussion
meantime senator let's switch gears
again
you're getting into the podcast game
with a podcast called
freedom rings tell us more about it
oh yes every time i would be across in
tennessee people would say
marcia tell me about some of the people
that are really
fighting for us so
we decided to start a podcast called
freedom
rings people can go to
freedomringspodcast.com
find out more or go to my political
website
at marsha blackburn and find out more
at vote marcia and what we have done
is to pull together some of these happy
warrior freedom fighters
you're kelly leffler senator rick scott
they're telling their stories about how
they grew up
senator people can find one more we got
to leave it there good luck with the
podcast